- Last time you we were here we talked
about your farm and it's
in the middle of nowhere.
- Yes.
- I love middle of nowhere.
That's where my ranch is.
I think it's amazing.
So how are things?
- No, they're, it's fine.
I mean, listen, it's winter time.
Yesterday it was 61 when I left,
tomorrow there's gonna be a foot of snow.
So the problem is
if there's wind and ice, the whole,
everything shuts down.
Nobody gets power and
we have two generators.
I am a lucky person.
We have two generators
and our one generator just blew,
two weeks ago with a huge ice storm.
I mean, you couldn't
even leave your house.
- Yeah.
- I just have two small kids
and in the middle of the
night have to have no heat.
Like we ended up having
to like walk outside
in five degree weather to
the barn and sleep there,
because we had a, the generator ran
for that 'cause it runs
for the horse barn.
- Yeah.
- And then the extra guest
barn and the house...
- So the animals were good.
Y'all were just cold.
(Kelly laughs)
- No, the animals are fine.
They're like, it's just,
there's like a cat room
where the cat lives and you know,
the cat at night goes in
and you have warmth for that
and water and running water.
So we were fine.
We were, we're very
lucky, but it was like one
of those things where like, I,
this is what you do.
This is what you gave up.
You sacrifice these
things when nature happens
you know what I mean?
And it's just..
- I love it.
Do you love it?
- The, no one running
water situation is like,
it'll kill me.
- It'll...( Kelly laughing)
(audience laughs)
- 2:30 a.m in the morning walking
with my one and a half
year old trying to wake up,
and my five year old
was like what an irony,
on I it was just like, no thanks.
But I really love my farm.